Donald Trump has cracked he Unleashed a
dangerous 60-plus post tirade on his
failing website truth social yesterday
trust Central this is now it's no longer
funny if it was ever funny it is
absolutely no longer funny Trump woke up
and went on a 60 post Q Anon fueled
social media spree writes Rolling Stone
now I am not going to publicize the
subject matter in detail of what Donald
Trump is posting here but I encourage
you just glance at Trump's truth Central
account and you will see derangement and
I I was scrolling scrolling scrolling
there is no shortage of memes and
conspiracy theories here it's just memes
and this is a former president folks
it's a former president
your enemy is not in Russia Trump
retrothing with pictures of Democrats
and George Soros That's a classic 81
million votes and I've never seen a
pro-biden hat shirt or flag in my life
right this is a thing on the right
if there aren't people sycophantically
wearing Biden memorabilia or
paraphernalia
he can't possibly have supporters well
maybe we on the left don't see these
elected officials like pseudo deities
I've never gotten gear for any elected
official I've supported because I have a
life and I will vote for them and then I
move on with my life and I don't get
hats or whatever the case may be
um
just all you know Orwell related memes
um
just all sorts of and and you could
spend an hour scrolling and half of
these memes are Q Anon related Trump
posting one it's like a photo this one's
actually funny but it's a little
Unbecoming of a president to post a a
Photoshop of Biden falling on the stairs
of Air Force One with a bicycle and a
helmet on the floor uh an ultra Maga
post America First
FBI sex tape conspiracy theories
um
weird things of Adam Schiff with an
exploding cigar
um you know you could you could just
look redacted with Nancy Pelosi's
eyebrows covered with black bars black
sensor bars
um stuff about the FBI
um a picture of a broken clock it just
oh and and it's just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
this is a very sick man and I believe is
it is a terrified man fundamentally
that's what I believe this is and by the
way folks the entire time I've been
talking I've been scrolling through the
memes Trump won
with Trump sitting at a desk a meme of
trump posting to Dollar gasoline
um we're still scrolling scrolling
scrolling scrolling any one of these if
we had a Democratic president posting
them would be cause for significant
concern and it is like 24 even a 30 hour
potentially upper fueled
uh
uh series of posts and it's endless I'm
still scrolling folks Still Still
scrolling so listen I think there's a
couple different things going on here I
think Trump is very scared I think Trump
at this point the RNC has all but
abandoned him they're no longer paying
his legal fees the pictures came out
where after all of the denials denials
denials that Donald Trump took uh
documents there are pictures of the
documents with his you know very cliche
Casino rugs in his apartment or
Mar-A-Lago Suite or whatever the hell is
where he lives uh and also he is
increasingly being abandoned by more
Republicans again the vast majority of
the Republican party is still behind him
but he is increasingly being abandoned I
think he's scared and I think he is
losing it um none of the excuses or the
lies are working he doesn't have Bill
Barr or the government at his disposal
to try to deflect he doesn't have Bill
Barr out there writing letters that say
oh Mueller exonerated him even though
when that's not actually what the
Mueller report said the guy is unhinged
and all he has left is his failing truth
Central and by the way that will
probably be underwater soon as well
so some could call it sad to me the sad
thing is he'll probably never really
face the consequences he deserves I know
that many of you who watch this show
also love documentaries if you don't
have curiosity stream you were missing
out our sponsor curiosity stream is the
only streaming platform specializing in
documentaries that's all they have
documentaries and this lets them deliver
the newest and most critically acclaimed
documentaries stuff you're not going to
find on other streaming services
curiosity stream also has a whole bunch
of super high quality original content
you won't find anywhere else the other
night I watched asteroids comets and
meteors as many of you know I'm super
interested in what seems to be the
inevitable direction we are going which
is the eventual mining of asteroids and
to be perfectly Frank I never remember
the difference between asteroids
comments and meteors and that's one of
the things that I learned check out
curiositystreams catalog you'll see they
have a much better better selection of
documentaries than the other platforms
they also have an app for your TV phone
tablet and computer and the best part is
my audience gets curiosity stream for
under two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below